in den trockner hätte nämlich meine
kamera frau keinen platz gefunden
so machen wir hier hinterher getrocknet
und das ist ja aufregend unterwegs sein
das ist wunderbar allerdings nur wenn
man weiß man kann auch wieder heim
für die 65 millionen menschen die
weltweit auf der flucht sind ich darf
nicht das zeigt nun eine beeindruckende
dokumentation
[Musik]
wie ist es wenn man nach einer langen
gefährlichen reise einen ort erreicht wo
niemand auf einen gewartet hat die
wanderausstellung flucht will uns
ahnungslosen auf die sprünge helfen und
hat den fehler macht hat mano khalil
dafür engagiert haben eigentlich alle
menschen sagen dass der flucht link es
ist kein fan ist in menschen wie sind
jeder von uns ganz lustig sein ich sage
es immer wieder endlich das kann uns
alles passieren
[Musik]
mano khalil gilt heute als schweizer
filmemacher vor 20 jahren kann er selbst
als politischer flüchtling aus syrien
hierher
nun soll er uns fühlen lassen wie es ist
flüchtling zu sein
den besucher der ausstellung will er
dafür zunächst nach aleppo führen mit
bildern wie er von freunden aus seiner
alten heimat bekommen hat diese bilder
da die die von aleppo man sieht ist
letzter das sind bilder wurden gewährt
in alle poren man sieht eine devise
dieses staates eines funktioniert
menschen
und heute in sines dunklen nicht mehr
gibt kein aufbauspiel eine katastrophe
alles was traurig manchmal aleppo die
schöne stadt eigentlich sieht das so
eine ruine wurde einfach eine ruine ist
das ist die linie
wiemer syrien wie vorher oder mano
khalil machte auch selbst viele
aufwärmen auf den fluchtrouten in den
flüchtlingslagern sprach mit menschen
die das gefühl haben ihre würde verloren
zu haben
es gibt es auch sachen die die man zeigt
sie nicht in seinen serien sind bilder
von menschen die die chance hat dann
eigentlich ihre ihre innere gefühle zu
erzählen oder darüber zu sprechen
ich habe versucht eigentlich wieder da
von meiner eigenen erfahrung von deiner
eigenen türe wurde zu sein
tiefer mittellange sich und zeigen so
war und saarland
so waren wir sind heute so
das ergebnis ist eine beeindruckende
videoinstallation das entree zur
ausstellung die ab 6 april in aarau zu
sehen ist
danach auch in bern und luzern es geht
auch darum möglichst nachzuempfinden wie
es den flüchtlingen gibt wenn sie in
europa ankommen wenn sie nicht mehr als
person wahrgenommen werden
alles in einem paket und alle werden
kontrolliert wenn es unangenehm dass
mein fuß ist so etwas von meiner wurde
es nicht mehr da ich bin der gleiche
mensch der das so in dieser augenhöhe
mit mid mid mid mid mit menschen
sprechen konnte sondern nicht immer so
bisschen gebrochen oder dann darf nicht
mehr so genau wird von menschen sprechen
das ist sowieso etwas verloren gegangen
etwas etwas etwas nicht nicht mehr da
ist so was man seine existenz sein traum
sein heimatland ein typischer raum in
einer schweizer asylunterkunft in der
ausstellung ist grobe liegen erlaubt und
das gedankenexperiment was würdest du
mitnehmen wenn du gezwungen wäre es zu
fliehen
oder ist das eine komplett naive frage
kenne die situation ich glaube nun mich
und meine lieben menschen
denn nur dann hätte fünf minuten um sein
sein haus zu verlassen
fünf minuten was man mit seine seele und
die seele von seinen lieben menschen mit
ohne gewähr dass sie auch heil ankommen
[Musik]